عام من التميز ختمتها العربيه في هذه
السنه بصراحه ارقام ملياريه على كافه
المنصات نحن اليوم نتحدث عن اكثر من مليار
مشاهده على منصات العربيه المختلفه
نتحدث عن اكثر من 220 حساب في هاي اللحظه
وفي كل لحظه عم يفتح عنا حسابات جديده نحن
لا نقول فقط ان العربيه هي الشاشه التي
يشاهدها المتابع وانما هي عباره عن شبكه
كبيره وضخمه من المنصات المختلفه التي
تقدم المحتوى باشكال مختلفه سواء كان
المحتوى القادم من شاشه العربيه او
المحتوى المنتج خصيصا من خلال فرق
السوشيال ميديا
او حتى المحتوى الذي يخاطب الدول العربيه
بصفحات مخصصه لهذه الدول ارقام العربيه
كبيره جدا وهي في ازدياد وقوه العربيه
تاتي دائما من خلال هذه الارقام التي تعكس
صراحه مدى ثقه الجمهور بالعربيه ومدى
اهتمامه بالمحتوى الذي يقدم على منصات
العربيه واللي هو بيعكس سياسه العربيه
المهنيه والحرفيه والى اخره عندما نتحدث
رشا عن ارقام منصات التواصل المختلفه على
سبيل المثال دعينا ننتقل مثلا لاخر تغطيه
تغطيه زلزال تركيا سوريا خلال هذه الفتره
العربيه حققت مليار و600 مليون مشاهده
وهذا الرقم قياسي جدا يعني تتحدثين عن
مليار و600 مليون مشاهده على ما نشهر من
محتوى على مختلف منصاتنا عندما نتحدث عن
220 حساب للعربيه نتحدث عن كميه هائله من
الحسابات التي تضخ باستمرار مثلا
نحن ننشر سنويا اكثر من مليون ونصف
المليون منشور ايضا هذا الرقم كثير ضخم
وبالتالي كل ما يقدم من محتوى على منصات
التواصل هو في الاساس وما ياتي من خلاله
من ارقام هو في الاساس يعكس الرساله التي
انشات من اجلها العربيه وهي ايصال
المعلومه وايصال الخبر وايصال الحقيقه
ونقل المعرفه للجمهور العربي اينما تواصل
عندما نتحدث عن المحتوى مثلا نتحدث عن
اشكال مختلفه من المحتوى هناك المحتوى
الذي ياتي من الشاشه كانت استراتيجيه
العربيه ان تقوم بنقل الشاشه مباشره الى
هاتف المتابع اين موجود فصرنا نقوم
باقتطاع كليبات صغيره من ما ينشر او مما
يبث على منصاتنا سواء على نشرات الاخبار
او البرامج وكل ما ينتج على الشاشه من
محتوى ونقوم باقتطاع كليبات صغيره حتى
نستطيع نوصل للمشاهد العربي المعلومه في
الوقت القياسي والسريع وبالوقت المختصر في
الوقت ذاته الشاشه دائما تزدحم بالاخبار
والملفات واحيانا هناك بعض المواضيع التي
لا يمكن للشاشه ان تغطيها لهذا السبب او
لذاك
لذلك قمنا بانشاء منتجات او محتوى مخصص
فقط السوشيال ميديا يعني ما بنشوفه على
الشاشه هذا المحتوى يلبي رغبات الجمهور
الواسع والمتنوع والموجود يعني بفئات
عمريه وناطق مختلفه
في بعض الاماكن رشا الدول عفوا الدول
العربيه على سبيل المثال مثلا في مصر او
في الجزائر او في تونس او في فلسطين هناك
صفحات للعربيه والحدث نتحدث عن الشبكه
تتناول الاخبار المحليه لهذه الدول واللي
ايضا الشاشه ربما لا تستطيع ان تغطيها في
هذا الوقت بسبب الانشغال والزحمه
الاخباريه الموجوده